you can't outrun who you really are
tonight don't miss
the new trailer
new trailer premiere during nba
countdown how's it going everybody it's
warren welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and today we have some
trailer news not just for spider-man no
way home but for
shang chi and the legend of the 10 rings
now as you just saw marvel studios
themselves released a promo
talking about how the shanghi trailer is
going to be shown tonight it's going to
be a full trailer it probably is going
to be like
what we saw for the falcon and the
winter soldier during the super bowl
marvel released about a 30 to 45 second
trailer for the falcon and the winter
soldier and then at the end of the
trailer they said that the full trailer
was online but they uploaded the full
trailer to youtube
and this released at the exact same time
that the trailer during the super bowl
released
so tonight during the game on espn which
by the way disney does
own marvel studios says they are
releasing a trailer for
shanxi and the legend of the tin ring so
it's probably going to be the same
about a 30 to 45 second trailer with a
full trailer being uploaded to youtube
at the same exact time
and already just for this teaser for
the trailer which is kind of interesting
but i like it they've shown us
new footage in this little teaser so we
can expect that the main trailer is
going to show us a lot more new footage
as well
and probably give us even more of a
backstory to what the plot is actually
going to be
and in this little teaser that we got
this morning we actually see the tin
rings being used we briefly got this
during the teaser for shanghai but since
this is going to be an
actual full trailer we'll probably learn
a lot more about the tin rings in this
trailer as well as see them being used
in a very different way than we're used
to because in marvel comics they're
actual rings that go on your fingers but
in shanghai and the mcu they're rings
that wrap around your arm kind of like
bracelets
so that's going to be tonight probably
around 5 30 p.m pacific time
and of course before we end this video
we have to talk about spider-man no way
home and where the heck
that trailer is now there is news about
the trailer but unfortunately it's not
exactly the best news
it seems like daniel richman has heard a
little bit more about when the trailer
is going to drop and apparently it's not
anytime soon although soon is a relative
word what he really means is it's not
going to be coming out this month and
probably not within the first half of
july
he stated on twitter remember when i
said the spidey trailer
is very likely to come out with black
widow that was a nice dream wasn't it so
the spidey trailer isn't coming out
with black widow which is july 9th and i
kind of expected this i didn't expect it
to come before
because we're dealing with loki right
now they're not going to want to take
the spotlight off of loki
especially with black widow coming out
at pretty much the same time they are
indeed going to
overlap for a week he then tweeted again
and said to be clear i don't know
when it's coming out yet i just know
it's not coming anytime soon
and then today he tweeted something very
interesting after the announcement of
the shang chi
trailer coming tonight he said we're
going to get two shang qi
trailers and an eternals trailer before
we get a no way home trailer and
unfortunately this
just makes sense because these movies
are before spider-man no way home now we
already have teasers for them and we
don't have a teaser for no way home but
you have to keep in mind that the teaser
for spider-man no way home is pretty
much going to break the entire internet
and marvel studios knows that and they
have to be careful with how they promote
that film so it doesn't overshadow all
of their other films
and most of you probably already see
this on the internet already
a lot of spider-man videos out there do
extremely well
because everybody is just dying to see
this trailer this trailer is going to
break records especially if it hints
even just a little bit at tobey maguire
and andrew garfield showing up so it
seems like they're being very strategic
about when exactly to release the
trailer
and i also did check with another source
of mine about the spider-man no way home
trailer and he pretty much said the
exact same thing
not coming this month not coming the
first half of next month
so it's not really coming anytime soon
unfortunately but of course as always if
i hear
anything at all i'll be sure to update
everybody in another video
luckily in the meantime while we wait
there is a lot to look forward to and
enjoy
loki shanghi apparently another eternals
trailer and just a bunch of awesome news
happening
every single day in the pop culture
world so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you